what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder I'm Warren Thompson
thanks for stopping by the channel today
and we have some really really
interesting news in regards to phase six
of the Marvel Cinematic Universe and
really just the entire MCU moving
forward there has been some recent
information that has come to light by a
very reputable author for Vanity Fair
and also the author of a new MCU book
coming out and some new information has
come out that stated that Kang the
Conqueror was not originally Marvel
Studios as plan as the big bad in the
MCU originally King the Conqueror was
not going to be really the focus of the
Multiverse Saga and now that Jonathan
majors has been arrested and is in some
trouble Marvel Studios is in a bit of a
pickle right now it's a very hard
situation on deciding whether or not to
recast Jonathan Majors but now it sounds
like the option of Simply moving away
from the character in general is on the
table original we thought hey they can
just recast and continue on with Kang
but apparently Marvel Studios had a lot
riding on Jonathan Majors himself so
with Jonathan Majors getting into
trouble recently that's really
interfering with Marvel studios's plan
and this author recently came out and
spoke about all of this so let's go
ahead and dive into everything that she
recently said and quick reminder we are
on patreon now we do also have an
official website and a Discord server if
you want to join that as well we'll link
all of those in the comments and the
description down below so this new
information about the MCU is coming from
author and journalist Joanna Robinson
she wrote the book MCU the reign of
Marvel Studios and that is coming out on
October 10th of this year she's also a
very reputable senior writer for Vanity
Fair and recently she was on the ringers
the big picture podcast where she opens
up on everything that she has heard
about Marvel Studios and their plans for
phase four Phase 5 5 and Phase 6 of the
MCU and how they were originally not
centered around Kang this is what she
said I was told by someone who works for
Marvel it was not the plan to make Kang
the center of everything until they saw
the dailies from quantumania and after
his performance in Loki which was so
strong they were like this is it this is
our way forward we've lost our Varsity
hero team but let's set up around this
guy Kang and this performer that so many
people are reacting to and what's
interesting is that she goes on to say
that she believes that Marvel has never
hung so much of a franchise on one
particular actor not even Iron Man she
goes on to say I don't think you or I
are very interested in saying what
Marvel should or shouldn't do going
forward but we know this is a huge
problem for them they are facing and
grappling with right now and what's
unprecedented and this for Marvel is I
would argue they have never hung so much
of a franchise on one actor as they
tried to hang it on Jonathan Majors
after his Loki performance and his
Ant-Man quantumania performance I would
argue more than Downey as Iron Man more
than brolinist Thanos that hanging
everything on this guy is then going to
pop up in all of their properties
leading up to something called the Kang
Dynasty has put them in a very unusual
position they don't usually hang so much
on one person in the way that they did
here and then when speaking about the
big problem that they are having right
now because of putting basically all of
their faith into one character and now
Jonathan major is getting into some
trouble she said and that has put them
in the bind we do not know what they're
going to do I've heard conflicting
stories about their going to replace him
they're not even considering replacing
him etc etc but it's just one more thing
now this is incredibly interesting for a
few different reasons one is yes that is
true Marvel Studios has never really put
all their eggs into one basket or one
actor or one performance or character
and that that seems to be what they're
doing now with Kang unfortunately the
problem with doing that is if something
happens like this you're kind of screwed
they kind of put everything revolving
around the Multiverse Saga into Jonathan
Majors as Kang and now that he's in some
trouble they are in a pretty big bind
but it is interesting as well to know
that kind of going into phase four they
maybe didn't have everything that mapped
out yet if they got into phase four and
then into phase 5's filming where they
saw Jonathan majors and Loki and then in
quantumania and decided wow this is it
that means that they either didn't have
a clear picture of what they wanted to
do for the Multiverse Saga or they did
have some sort of a picture and villain
plan but they simply pushed that aside
and decided to make Jonathan Majors as
Kang the main big bat villain and
knowing Marvel Studios they did have
somewhat of a plan Kevin feige has even
said that even what you see has already
been mapped out for example we already
have phase five and some of phase six he
says that they have planned five to six
years past those movies now they can
plan the movies but maybe not have all
the connectivity planned out yet which
seems to be kind of what they did here
they had a general outline but didn't
have it all kind of planned out and
here's where it gets complicated but
also kind of interesting we've heard a
lot around Jonathan majors and based off
of what Disney has done so far removing
his name and even the mention of Kang
the Conqueror from pretty much all of
their promos is very interesting and it
does point to the fact that they are in
a bind here they're in a pickle it's
hard for them and they may have to
recast King and there's now kind of two
options here one is to Simply recast him
get another actor to take his place and
everything Remains the Same as far as
the Multiverse Saga goes or they could
kind of push his character to the side
originally there was some sort of a
Multiverse Saga blueprint that existed
where it came the Conqueror was not the
main focus and it is totally possible
for Marvel Studios to kind of revert
back to that we are not that deep into
the Multiverse Saga yet only two movies
into phase five and Guardians of the
Galaxy by volume 3 doesn't really affect
any of the connected story of the
Multiverse Saga anyways so we're not too
far into it to bring in another villain
we could still conclude a Kang story but
Marvel Studios could take a different
direction than having Kang be the
ultimate big bad villain there are other
characters out there that could play a
huge role in secret Wars Dr Doom being
one of them and I think that if they had
to replace Kang as a villain Dr Doom
would actually be kind of a perfect fit
because he is big enough and loved
Enough by Marvel fans that they wouldn't
be too let's say pissed off that they
changed the king story now I for one am
hoping that they simply if they have to
recast him in a perfect world Jonathan
Majors stays as king the court finds him
innocent Disney decides to keep him on
everything proceeds as scheduled but if
they had to get rid of Jonathan Majors I
think the route to go down is to Simply
recast not to sideline the character
sadly it is a possibility they could
simply kind of tie up his story sooner
rather than them later and not go into
Secret Wars with him the only problem
there would be the Kang Dynasty the next
Avengers film is literally called the
King Dynasty it has Kang in the name
that's gonna be a hard one to sidestep
from sure Marvel Studios could come out
and simply say hey you guys have heard
what happened for that reason Avengers
the next one is going to be about
something else however that's a very
hard route to go down and I don't
believe Marvel Studios will do that I
believe that if something happens
they'll recast King the Conqueror and
then they will complete the Kang Dynasty
what they do from there could be
completely different Kang might not be
so involved in secret Wars they could
bring in somebody else to be a main
villain and they could start introducing
that villain in Phase 5 to build him up
build him up more than Kang so right now
Marvel Studios and Disney are faced with
a pretty huge Dilemma on what exactly to
do with the MCU do they revert back to
their old original plan before they
decided to make Kang the focus of the
Multiverse Saga or do they simply recast
the character and hope that another
actor they bring in can do just as good
of a job as Jonathan Majors did
obviously his performance was so great
and impactful to them that they went wow
this is who we need to Center everything
around and I agree every performance
that we've seen of Jonathan Majors as he
who remains or Kang has been phenomenal
it's a very unfortunate situation but
let's hope that Disney and Marvel
Studios handle it the right way and in
the meantime let us know your thoughts
Below on what you think Marvel Studios
should actually do what would you be
happy with a recast of King Jonathan
Majors remaining as Kang or maybe Marvel
Studios moving on to have another
villain be the main villain of the
Multiverse Saga let us know all of your
thoughts down below also don't forget to
like the video subscribe and leave a
comment so you can enter our giveaway
for a chance to win an Xbox series X A
PS5 some Marvel Legends items or some DC
items the winner gets to pick one item
and we pick a winner at the end of each
month you can also follow us on
Instagram and Twitter as well and as
always thank you all so much for
watching wolf
please